[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
Abend seit heute Mittag um 13 Uhr sind
die deutsch-ukrainischen Beziehungen ein
bisschen unkomplizierter geworden man
kann sich sogar ein heimliches aufatmen
in Kanzleramt und
Verteidigungsministerium vorstellen denn
heute überreichte der neue ukrainische
Botschafter olexie marquev dem
Bundespräsidenten das
abberufungsschreiben seines Vorgängers
andre Melnik ukrainischer Botschafter
und Quälgeist deutscher Politik
zurückversetzt nach Kiew der neue ist
ebenso wie Melnik Karriere Diplomat
fließend deutschsprechend und genauso
fordernd nur eben leiser berichtet
Andreas Kühnast aus Berlin
dass sich für einen neuen Botschafter an
dessen allererstem Berliner Arbeitstag
sieben acht neun zehn Fotografen
interessieren kommt nur bei sehr
brisanten Ländern vor oder bei sehr
brisanten Botschaftern
olexemakev ist 46 seit 26 Jahren im
diplomatischen Dienst und das Gegenteil
von brisant das Gegenteil seines
Vorgängers André Melnik den man aus der
Berliner Ampel Koalition nicht mal zum
Abschied etwas Freundliches nachruft
das muss man sagen hat vielleicht den
Beruf verfehlt er ist ja hier im
diplomatischen Dienst tätig gewesen und
Diplomatie war nicht sein Thema Berlin
gehört zu den wichtigsten Hauptstädten
für die Ukraine und es ist auf Dauer
dann doch nicht egal wenn der
Botschafter aus Kiew unbeliebter ist als
zum Beispiel der aus Moskau was etwas
heißen will man sieht sehr gerne
Russlands Mann in Berlin selten seit
Kriegsbeginn und wenn dann vor allem in
russischen Medien aber ausgerechnet
heute lässt nichtarjew Kritik auf
Deutsch veröffentlichen am
antirussischen Eifer durch russophobe
Protagonisten die die deutsch-russische
Zusammenarbeit zerstört hätten
als der neue Vertreter der Ukraine
gefragt hat wie man umgeht mit dem
Vertreter Russlands wie man redet mit
dem Feind hat der alte gesagt gar nicht
Lust hatte ich keine wegen des Krieges
und es gab auch keine Notwendigkeit also
hätte es sie gegeben vielleicht würde
ich über den Schatten springen und auch
mit ihm kommunizieren aber das war
leider nicht möglich um Verständnis für
ukrainische Gefühle muss jetzt markiert
werden und um politische militärische
und wirtschaftliche Hilfe auch eine
wichtige Zusage kann er schon nach Kiew
melden an seinem ersten Tag
wir wollen dass die Ukraine Teil der
Europäischen Union wird
diese Entscheidung sendet auch ein
Signal an private Investoren wer heute
in den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
investiert der investiert in einen
künftiges EU Mitgliedsland das Teil sein
wird unser rechts-gemeinschaft und
unseres Binnenmarkts deutsche Wirtschaft
und deutsche Politik bekennen sich zum
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine ein hunderte
Milliarden Euro versprechen da sind so
viele Interessierte
und da ist das Fotomotiv Bundespräsident
und Botschafter keinen deutschen
Politiker hat makeews Vorgänger so
geärgert so genervt wie diesen Manix
Nachfolger muss und soll nicht ganz so
Bisig sein ich wünsche Ihnen wirklich
von Herzen viel Glück weil davon wie
Deutschland uns unterstützt um diesen
Krieg schneller zu beenden hängen so
viele Leben aus ab in der Ukraine und
ich hoffe dass er das auch besser macht
als ich noch hat der neue kein Interview
gegeben nicht mal ein kurzes makeef ist
anders als Melnik aber er hat den
gleichen Auftrag das werden die
Deutschen schon noch merken
heute und morgen also geht es auf gleich
zwei Berliner Konferenzen um den
Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine heute mehr
um schnelle Hilfe für den kommenden
Winter morgen eher um die langfristige
Perspektive wir sprechen gleich mit
einem Unternehmer der heute in Berlin
dabei war aber zunächst Christian von
Rechenberg mit einer sehr vorläufigen
Schadensbilanz was tun wenn der Winter
kommt Millionen Menschen brauchen ein
Dach über dem Kopf Wasser Strom das
lebenswichtige hat Putin ins Visier
genommen 40% der Energieanlagen etwa
sind getroffen das Licht geht aus in der
Ukraine und der Internationale
Währungsfonds bilanziert düsteres
Einbruch der Wirtschaft explodierende
Preise der Handel massiv gestört die
Staatsfinanzen in dramatischer
Schieflage was alles kaputt ist schwer
zu sagen bereits nach den ersten Wochen
des Krieges zählte der Währungsfond
dutzende zerstörte Krankenhäuser Straßen
Br hunderte zerstörte Schulen tausende
zerstörte Wohnanlagen seitdem sind
Monate vergangen einiges konnten sie
wieder aufbauen längst nicht alles und
das Bombardement hört nie auf kaum
jemand kann das in stabile Zahlen Gießen
Orientierung gibt die Weltbank sie
schätzt allein die Schäden auf 350
Milliarden Euro die Ukraine auf mehr als
das Doppelte und die Menschen brauchen
noch mehr Lohn Rente Sozialleistungen
einige Milliarden an Hilfe sind
geflossen es reicht hinten und vorne
nicht
und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt Michael
Kraus Manager des osteuropa-geschäfts
der fixit-gruppe die Baustoffe herstellt
Mörtel putze Dämmmaterial guten Abend
nach Wien wohin sie in der Zwischenzeit
geflogen sind Herr Kraus ihre
Firmengruppe hat zwei Werke in der
Ukraine in Kiew und in Lemberg nehmen
Sie uns doch mal mit dahin wie können
sie dort überhaupt im Moment arbeiten
und produzieren
ja schönen guten Abend Frau gelenik wir
halten die Fahne aufrecht wir
produzieren an unserem Hauptstandort 80
Kilometer südlich von Kiew in unserem
baustoffwerk wie es auch immer möglich
ist unter Beachtung der starken
Sicherheitsvorschriften wir befinden uns
in einem Zustand des kriegsrechtes was
natürlich unternehmerische
Einschränkungen bedeutet aber Security
first und safety also für unsere
Mitarbeiter die Sicherheit der
Mitarbeiter und unserer Anlagen haben
absolut den Vorrang dasselbe gilt
natürlich auch unterbreche welche
Einschränkungen sind das die das
Kriegsrecht für sie bedeutet
eingeschränkte Nachtarbeit Verdunkelung
Abstimmung mit lokalen Behörden abhängig
von der von der jeweiligen
Sicherheitslage vor Ort das kann sich ja
sehr schnell ändern und leider befindet
sich unser Werk auch in einem relativ
wichtig strategisch Skigebiet südlich
von Kiew und nicht ausgeschlossen ist
dass es zu Angriffen kommt und leider
hat die Vergangenheit auch schon das
gezeigt dass die benachbarte Stadt
getroffen worden ist von Raketen und
auch unsere Kleinstadt wo unser
Werkstatt steht leider einiges an
Schäden
verzeichnen musste durch Beschuss mit
Raketen wie kommen Ihre Mitarbeiter wie
kommt Ihre Firma jetzt durch den Winter
also haben sie Strom haben sie
Generatoren können Sie die Sicherheit
Ihrer Mitarbeiter gewährleisten
wir tun alles um die Sicherheit unserer
Mitarbeiter zu gewährleisten um einen
Weiterbetrieb des Werkes über den Winter
hinweg zu gewährleisten wir haben
natürlich gewisse Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
zusätzlich getroffen und
verfügen über Strom verfügen auch über
die notwendige Infrastruktur um
in Anführungszeichen ungestört
produzieren zu können sofern das aus der
Sicherheitslage zulässig und möglich ist
und ich möchte auch betonen unsere Leute
unsere Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
wollen arbeiten die stehen wirklich
jeden Tag zur Verfügung egal wie
kritisch die Lage ist sie kommen in die
Arbeit sie machen ihren Job an allen
Standorten an allen drei Standorten sei
es in der Hauptverwaltung in Kiew sei es
im Werk südlich von Kiew oder seis an
unserem neu entwickelten oder gerade in
Entwicklung befindlichen Standort in
Lemberg heute bei der Berliner Konferenz
hatten sie ja sozusagen als Praktiker
als Unternehmer das Wort wie können sie
wie kann die deutsche Wirtschaft der
Ukraine denn jetzt helfen in dieser
Situation
ich glaube das war halt ein ganz
wichtiger Tag für die Ukraine wir hatten
ganz einstimmiges Statements des
Bundeskanzlers des Vizekanzlers
verschiedener Minister
die sich eindeutig geäußert haben dass
die Unterstützung für die Ukraine auch
weiterhin bestehen bleibt und
möglicherweise verstärkt wird wir als
Wirtschaft wir als Unternehmer und
Unternehmer müssen jetzt auch leisten
wir müssen dieses Versprechen einlösen
und der ukrainischen Bevölkerung zur
Seite stehen und nicht nur unseren
Mitarbeitern sondern überhaupt der
gesamten ukrainischen Wirtschaft es ist
schon mehrmals erwähnt worden
Infrastruktureinrichtungen zivile
Einrichtungen werden hier nach wie vor
bombardiert Wärme ein also wäre mir
erzeugungseinrichtungen
Elektrizitätswerke alles was wichtig ist
für um über den Winter zu kommen ist
primäres Ziel geworden und hier sind wir
alle gefordert alles Menschen Mögliche
zu tun um vor Ort zu unterstützen mit
unseren Möglichkeiten
Rahmenbedingungen brauchen sie denn für
den Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine oder
anders gefragt welche Erfahrungen haben
sie mit Korruption in der Ukraine
gemacht ohne Bestechungsgelder läuft da
ja anscheinend nicht sehr viel
ich würde das nicht zur pauschaliert
sagen ich bin seit knapp 15 Jahren
unterwegs in der Ukraine und muss auch
sagen seit 2014 ist die Ukraine doch
eine Erfolgsstory wir haben demokratisch
legitimierte Regierungen wir haben
Grundrechte wir haben Pressefreiheit wir
haben Meinungsfreiheit wir haben einen
massive Verringerung der Bürokratie und
die Ukraine kennt ihre Hausaufgaben und
diese Hausaufgaben müssen gemacht werden
und es ist ein langer Weg aber es wird
besser die Richtung stimmt die Tendenz
stimmt und ich glaube dieses
kriegerische geschehen und diese
fürchterlichen Vorfälle von denen wir
jetzt alle Zeugen werden wirken noch als
katill Katalysator ich denke das wird
diesen Reinigungsprozess auch den
inneren Reinigungsprozess in der Ukraine
noch beschleunigen ich kann nur sagen
die letzten Jahre ist viel Fortschritt
erzählt worden von allen Regierungen die
hier am Ruder waren natürlich ist es ein
steiniger Weg ein langer Weg mit vielen
gegenlaufenden Interesse aber ich glaube
inzwischen verstehen alle auch in der
Ukraine das ist keinen anderen Weg gibt
als diese Altlasten über Bord zu werfen
und sich auf das neue zu konzentrieren
und wo wir können unterstützen wir gerne
mit Werten und und jeglicher Form der
Unterstützung sagt ein Mann aus der
Praxis Herr Kraus herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch
vielen
Abend nach Wien und im heute journal
Update gegen halb eins empfehlen wir
Ihnen noch ein Gespräch mit Thomas
kleine Brockhoff vom German Marshall
fand über einen neuen Marshallplan für
die Ukraine
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Nachrichten von Gundula und die beginnen
mit der Aussicht auf weitere Entlastung
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck will
Entlastungen beim Strompreis spätestens
im Januar erreicht haben analog zur
geplanten gaspreisbremse die ab März für
private Haushalte und kleinere Firmen
kommen soll müsse es auch beim
Stromverbrauch finanzielle Hilfe geben
und das früher als bislang erwartet
sagte der grünen Politiker dem
Handelsblatt das Geld wolle die
Regierung über die Abschöpfung von
zufallsgewinnen bei Stromproduzenten
einholen
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
hat die Bundeswehr Eliteeinheit KSK
besucht und ihr nach der Aufarbeitung
rechtsextremistischer Vorfälle ihr
vollstes Vertrauen ausgesprochen die KSK
sei reformiert und eine besonders
betroffene Kompanie aufgelöst worden
erklärte Lambrecht einige Soldaten
hatten sich vor zwei Jahren in rechten
chatgruppen ausgetauscht außerdem waren
bei einem KSK-Soldaten in Sachsen
Sprengstoff und
illegale Waffen gefunden worden
Bundespräsident Steinmeier fordert mehr
Engagement gegen Feindseligkeit und
Vorurteile gegenüber Sinti und Roma in
Deutschland die alltägliche
Diskriminierung müsse aufhören sagte er
bei einem Festakt zum zehnjährigen
Bestehen des Denkmals für die Sinti und
Roma die im Nationalsozialismus ermordet
worden waren erneut Bart Steinmeier
dafür um Vergebung und warnte zugleich
vor rechtsradikalen Kräften in ganz
Europa
in Myanmar sind bei einem Luftangriff
des Militärs bis zu 80 Menschen getötet
worden hunderte sollen teils schwer
verletzt und noch ohne medizinische
Versorgung sein die getroffene
unabhängigkeitsorganisation behauptet
der Angriff habe Feiernden Mitgliedern
gegolten dagegen erklärte die Militär
runter Ziel sei der bewaffnete Arm der
Organisation gewesen
an einer Schule im US-Bundesstaat
Missouri hat es wieder eine
schusswaffenattacke gegeben drei
Menschen wurden getötet darunter von der
Polizei der Angreifer selbst der etwa
20-Jährige Schütze war in die Highschool
eingedrungen und er schoss aus nach
unbekannten Motiv eine Frau und eine
jugendliche sechs weitere Menschen
wurden verletzt innerhalb weniger
Minuten waren dutzende Polizisten an dem
Schulgebäude das von Sicherheitsleuten
bewacht war
es gibt eine neue corona-sub-variante
sie heißt
bq.1.1 und ist auch ein immunflüchter
das heißt dass es Antikörpern die durch
Impfung oder Genesung entstanden sind
besser entkommt also Menschen trotzdem
ansteckt noch sind die nachgewiesenen
Fallzahlen in Deutschland gering
beunruhigend aber ist das Tempo der
Ausbreitung nicht nur wegen
bq.1.1 ist die corona-lage
unübersichtlich die Länder
Gesundheitsminister die sich heute
zusammenschalteten gründeten einen
Arbeitskreis um über eine abgestimmte
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen
nachzudenken mit anderen Worten sie
wissen auch nicht recht was zu tun ist
unsere Porta Peter Böhmer hat sich
angesehen wie sich die Essener Uniklinik
auf den corona-
Visite heute Nachmittag auf der
Intensivstation 2 der Uniklinik Essen in
den letzten Wochen sind die Zahlen der
Patienten mit corona-infektion
angestiegen 47 waren es vor einem Monat
heute sind es 79 davon 14 auf der
Intensivstation aber keine großen
op-verschiebungen bisher die Lage
beherrschbar also auf keinen Fall gibt
es aktuellen Grund Panik zu machen wir
sind jetzt oder wir gehen jetzt in den
dritten corona-winter hinein wir haben
den letzten drei Jahren extrem viel
lernen können so dass wir wie gesagt
glaube ich in die Zukunft einigermaßen
entspannt schauen können bundesweit
scheint Corona mal wieder eine Pause
einzulegen doch niemand weiß wie lange
die sieben Tage Inzidenz ist laut RKI in
den letzten Tagen deutlich gesunken
die Belegung der Intensivstationen mit
corvette-patienten schauen sich laut der
rki-zahlen derzeit zu stabilisieren
und doch haben sie in den Kliniken wie
in Essen ein Problem Personalausfall
auch wegen Corona um die zwei Kollegen
fallen immer aus sind dann tagelang in
Quarantäne hinzu kommt von den 62
Planstellen vor Corona sind nur noch 50
besetzt viele kamen mit dem Stress nicht
klar es sind erfahrene Mitarbeiter
gegangen teilweise höchst erfahrene mit
10 20 30 Jahren intensiv Erfahrung und
die fehlen die fehlen es kommen junge
Kollegen nach die sind motiviert nett
freundlich aber den fehlen leider zehn
Jahre intensive Erfahrung ich sage mal
die corona-pandemie die ersten zwei
Jahre hat uns sicherlich in der
Entwicklung fünf bis sechs Jahre nach
hinten geworfen die Personal Lücken
müssen sie mit Zeitarbeitern schließen
doch nach vorne geschaut ist auch klar
Corona ist beherrschbarer geworden
mildere Varianten die Impfungen neue
Medikamente für Virologen geht der Weg
in eine Normalität zu der eine Infektion
dazugehört
die sommerwelle war ja auch schon
relativ heftig und die war natürlich
ärgerlich aber sie hat in unserer
Gesamtbevölkerung natürlich auch die
Immunitätslage noch mal verbessert wir
müssen einfach damit rechnen dass ein
Großteil der Bevölkerung auch irgendwann
sich infizieren muss und zusätzlich noch
eine Immunität aufbauen muss die Frage
ist welche Mutationen das Virus noch
hervorbringt und wie gefährlich solche
Varianten werden können
bq11 etwa dass sich derzeit rasant
ausbreitet in Essen mahnen sie
jedenfalls weiterhin zur Vorsicht wir
sind jetzt aktuell bei knapp 1.800
Intensivpatienten deutschlandweit das
ist wie gesagt ein Bruchteil dessen was
wir in der maximal Variante werden der
zweiten und dritten Welle im Endeffekt
hatten ich würde nicht von Entspannung
sprechen ich würde sagen es zeigt dass
wir auf keinem schlechten Wege unterwegs
sind es sollte uns aber alle zur
Vorsicht mahnen aufgrund dessen weil wir
jetzt noch eine sehr warme Jahreszeit
aktuell haben der Herbst ist extrem warm
der richtige Winter kommt erst noch wenn
wir uns alle in die geschlossenen Räume
zurückziehen und dann müssen wir gucken
wie weitergeht sie sind froh um jeden
Patienten ohne corona-infektion den sie
dann eben nicht isolieren müssen das
erleichtert die Arbeit des knappen
Personals immens
Großbritannien hat einen neuen
Premierminister und uff es ist nicht
Boris Johnson Boris Johnson hatte
gestern Abend überraschend seine
Kandidatur zurückgezogen es steht zu
vermuten dass er es nicht tat weil er
sich für nicht geeignet hält seine
Begründung der Zeitpunkt sei nicht
richtig das klingt nun wieder so als
wolle er erstmal seinen nach Nachfolger
Richie sonak den Karren aus dem Dreck
ziehen lassen der regissonak den die
konservative torri-partei eigentlich gar
nicht leiden kann weil er ein reicher
Investmentbanker war und weil er als
Finanzminister Boris Johnson im Sommer
fallen ließ vom Königsmörder zum
Premierminister Yasin herlein berichtet
dunkles Grau scheint die bevorzugte
Anzugfarbe der Herren vom sogenannten
1922 Komitee zu sein die Schienen auch
heute wieder ihren Auftritt zu genießen
beim verkünden dessen was die
konservative Partei diesmal ausgeheckt
hat
ich kann bestätigen dass wir nur eine
gültige Nominierung haben
erschießtunak ist somit als Vorsitzender
der konservativen Partei gewählt
was in diesen Tagen gleichbedeutend ist
mit dem Amt des Premierministers es ist
bereits der dritte im laufenden Jahr vor
dem Hauptquartier der Tories feierten
sie den neuen trotzdem als sei nichts
gewesen
ob es an der Schwere der bevorstehenden
Aufgabe lag oder an seinem
Redenschreiber regissonaks erste Worte
an Partei und Volk wirken seltsam
Hölzern und definitiv abgelesen
es besteht kein Zweifel dass wir uns
einer großen wirtschaftlichen
Herausforderung stellen müssen wir
brauchen jetzt Stabilität und Einigkeit
und ich werde es zu meiner allerhöchsten
Priorität machen unsere Partei und unser
Land zu einem
möglich geworden war die Kühe des
ehemaligen Finanzministers allerdings
erst durch den Rückzug Boris Johnsons
der hatte übers Wochenende noch einmal
kräftig für Wirbel gesorgt das kann er
gut und macht er gerne Alex zurück vom
Karibikurlaub sondierte der ex-prämie ob
es bei seinen Parteifreunden genügend
Rückhalt für ein Comeback gäbe er kam
wohl zu dem Schluss dass dies nicht der
Fall war
so viel Vernunft und Uneigennützigkeit
verblüffte selbst alte Weggefährten die
aber nichtsdestotrotz nach und nach zu
sunak überliefen der ist der erste
Premierminister asiatischer Herkunft und
mit 42 der jüngste seit über 200 Jahren
und einer der reichsten die dieses Amt
jemals inne hatten in einem Land das
nicht zuletzt durch die Fehler seiner
Vorgängerin in einer schweren
wirtschaftlichen Krise steckt wünschen
sie sich vor allem eines
eine Regierung der man trauen kann die
die Dinge vernünftig angeht und uns
nicht über den Tisch zieht
die Opposition fordert nach dem Chaos
der letzten Wochen weiterhin Neuwahlen
wir können uns nicht jeden Monat einen
neuen Premierminister vor die Nase
setzen weil bei ihnen totales
Durcheinander herrscht und sie keine
Schimmer von den Problemen haben vor der
die Lebenshaltungskosten die Leute
stellt
doch Parlamentswahlen wird es
möglicherweise erst in zwei Jahren geben
sollte es premiers synag gelingen seine
Partei jetzt unter Kontrolle zu bringen
und das Land zur Ruhe kommen zu lassen
und weiter geht es mit Gundula und
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft in den
regierungsinternen Beratungen über eine
Beteiligung des chinesischen
costco-konzerns an einem
Containerterminal des Hamburger Hafens
zeichnet sich offenbar eine
Kompromisslösung ab mehrere Medien
berichten aus Regierungskreisen das
cosco nicht wie geplant 35% des
Terminals übernehmen darf sondern nur
24,9%. somit hätte die chinesische
staatsrederei als Minderheitsaktionär
formal keinen inhaltlichen Einfluss auf
die Geschäftsführung
angesichts der drohenden Rezession wird
es für Unternehmen offenbar schwieriger
neue Kredite zu erhalten das geht aus
einer Umfrage des Münchner Ifo-Instituts
hervor zwischen steigenden Zinsen und
hoher Inflation Stefanie berrett Gerät
die Wirtschaft zunehmend in eine
Zwickmühle ganz genau Gundula viele
Unternehmen schleppen ja bereits seit
corona-kreditlasten mit sich herum und
müssen nun on top steigende Preise und
teure Energiekosten Schultern ohne
zusätzliche Kredite steht da bei
etlichen Unternehmen des wirtschaftliche
Überleben auf der Kippe in dieser
kritischen Gemengelage agieren Banken
natürlich zunehmend vorsichtiger laut
evo-institut erlebt derzeit fast ein
Viertel aller Unternehmen zurückhaltende
Banken bei der Kreditvergabe besonders
schwer trifft es dabei Kleinstbetriebe
und Solo-Selbstständige hier registriert
jede zweite Firma Probleme bei ihren
Kreditanfragen während kleine
Unternehmen also eher schwer an Kredite
kommen haben die 150 größten Konzerne
Deutschlands Dank Zinsen Milliarden
Kredite wie nie zuvor aufgetürmt laut
Handelsblatt kletterte der Schuldenstand
binnen eines Jahres um satte 20 Prozent
auf 533 Milliarden Euro der DAX-Konzern
mit der höchsten Verschuldung übrigens
die Deutsche Telekom sie hat sich in den
letzten Jahren Milliarden Investitionen
vor allem in den USA geleistet über die
Schuldenberge der großen schaut man hier
am Aktienmarkt heute großzügig hinweg
stattdessen gewinnt der DAX zum
Wochenstart 200 Punkte und schließt nur
knapp unter 13.000 Punkten zwei Faktoren
sorgten hier für Rückenwind zum einen
wird die US-Notenbank möglicherweise das
Tempo bei ihren Zinserhöhungen
rausnehmen zum anderen herrschte große
Erleichterung über den kräftig
gefallenen Gaspreis vielen Dank Stefanie
für alle Informationen nach Frankfurt
im vergangenen Jahr gab es so wenig
Autodiebstähle wie noch nie nach Angaben
der Versicherer waren es rund 9.800 8%
weniger als im Vorjahr Mitte der 1990er
Jahre wurden rund 100.000 Autos pro Jahr
gestohlen Gründe sind die heute Weg
vorhandenen Wegfahrsperren sowie bessere
Grenzkontrollen laut Polizei dominieren
Banden aus Osteuropa den Handel mit
gestohlenen Pkw darunter vor allem teure
Geländewagen
die EU hat endgültig die Einführung
eines einheitlichen Ladekabels für
Elektrogeräte beschlossen die
Umweltminister der Europäischen Union
billigten die entsprechende Richtlinie
damit müssen in der EU verkaufte
Elektrogeräte wie Handys und Tablets bis
spätestens Ende 2024 über einen
usb-c-anschluss verfügen Laptops ab
Frühjahr 2026 Ziel ist weniger
Elektroschrott
Paris feiert die internationale
Kunstmesse Art Paris als vollen Erfolg
der neue Ableger einer der weltweit
wichtigsten Messen für Gegenwartskunst
derart Basel fand zum ersten Mal an der
sandstadt zehntausende Kunstsammler
bescherten den Galerien Millionen
Umsätze im nächsten oktober soll die
Kunstmesse wieder im Grand Palais e
fimer am Eiffelturm stattfinden
ausführlich berichtet das heute journal
Update um 0 Uhr
deutsche Helden heißen schon lange
heißen schon lange nicht mehr Kriemhild
oder Siegfried sondern sie heißen Katar
Shirin oder Özlem sagt der Regisseur
Fatih Akin und meint damit seinen neuen
Kinofilm Reingold Rheingold weil der
Held des Films der kurdisch iranische
Rapper Hatha in Bonn am Rhein aufwächst
Rheingold auch weil er später einen
spektakulären Goldraub begeht um
Schulden bei einem Drogenkartell zu
begleichen der Film erzählt die
unwahrscheinliche und trotzdem wahre
Geschichte des Abrutschens und des
märchenhaften Aufstiegs eines
migrantischen Jugendlichen in
Deutschland inzwischen ist rapperatar
selbst eine Legende Nadja nasser hat
Rheingold gesehen
er nennt sich Rattan auf Kurdisch der
gefährliche gangster rapper und
exkrimineller mit packender
Lebensgeschichte seine
kurdisch-iranische Familie flieht 1985
vor Gefängnis und Folter nach
Deutschland zu Hause im Iran war der
Vater ein gefeierter Komponist und
Dirigent in Bonn ist der ein niemand
der kleine chihuahui hatar eigentlich
heißt sollen nach Willen des Vaters
ebenfalls Musiker werden den Traum vom
Aufstieg Leben im Land von Wagner und
Beethoven die Realität sieht anders aus
seine neue Heimat ist ein sozialer
Brennpunkt Ihr Gerät schnell aus Not auf
die schiefe Bahn rutscht immer tiefer ab
ins kriminelle Milieu
das ist ganz klar es ist ein Film über
Deutschland und so was wie
Chancengleichheit und so und der Ausweg
durch Bildung also was da und das
dass das stimmt halt nur bedingt ist
narrativ es ist ein narrativ es war
jetzt nicht als sozialkritischer Film
gedacht aber klar es ist halt es ist
eine ein hartes Land in dem ihr Leben
Spiel mal was kommt der hochbegabte
junge Mann großartig gespielt von Emilio
sakraya träumt von einem Ausweg er will
Musik machen aber nicht die klassische
seines Vaters er entdeckt den Rap für
sich beschreibt sich den harten Alltag
von der Seele
Blut in der Küche Blut in der Küche
meine Eltern hassen sich Gewalt zu Hause
ist anders als auf der Straße
aber jeder Versuch aus dem kriminellen
Milieu auszubrechen geht schief führt zu
immer waghalsigeren Aktionen
wie geht das guckst du verlieren Bruder
mit einem echten Schurkenstück kommt er
schließlich in die Schlagzeilen er
überfällt mit Freunden einen
goldtransporter verkleidet als Polizist
[Musik]
Rheingold ist ein rasanter Film geworden
mal milieu-studie mal Gangsterfilm mal
bittere Komödie
also ein dramaturgischen Bogen wie sein
Leben den den kann man nicht finden das
war so eine so die ultimative Geschichte
über Flucht und Vertreibung und Aufstieg
und Abstieg und Wiederaufstieg es war so
alles da drin und Irrwege für Jahre
landet rattar im Gefängnis nimmt da sein
erstes Album auf okay jetzt kommt die
erste Strophe einziges Instrument ist
ein Diktiergerät und er trifft mit
seiner Musik einen Nerv der echte Katar
ist heute erfolgreicher Rapper und
Unternehmer und setzt sich mit seiner
Stiftung für benachteiligte Jugendliche
ein fertig Akin erzählt seine bewegte
Geschichte von Migration tiefem Fall und
Neuanfang vielschichtig und unterhaltsam
wenn ich rauskomme bin ich wohl ein
anderer Mann
[Musik]
das Gold aus dem Überfall ist übrigens
Weg Katar hat nie preisgegeben was er
damit gemacht hat wir sollen den Abspann
lesen hat er in einem Interview gesagt
ab Donnerstag läuft Reingold im Kino und
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit der
Krimiserie vidual tot auf hoher See und
es ist Christina von Ungarn Sternberg
die sich später mit unserem heute
journal Update meldet uns gibt es morgen
wieder um 21 Uhr tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter morgen mittag gibt
es am Himmel über Deutschland wieder ein
besonderes Schauspiel eine partielle
Sonnenfinsternis der Mond schiebt sich
ein Stück vor die Sonne und verdeckt sie
zum Teil dabei wirft er einen
Halbschatten auf die Erde zu sehen ist
das zuerst auf Island dann wandert der
Schatten weiter über Europa in
Deutschland kann man das ab kurz nach 11
sehen Nordosten ist eine Stunde später
etwa ein Drittel der Sonne verdeckt im
Süden Deutschlands allerdings weniger
auf keinen Fall sollte man die partielle
Sonnenfinsternis mit bloßen Auge
betrachten sonst drohen Augenschäden
und die besten Bedingungen um dieses
Schauspiel dann zu betrachten sind dann
im Süden Deutschlands wir schauen in die
Nacht und da gibt es shower im Westen
und die ziehen Richtung Nordosten weiter
in Gewässernähe zum Beispiel an der
Donau gibt es wieder Nebel 13 Grad
tiefswerte am Niederrhein und sieben
Grad am Alpenrand das ist die
Temperaturspanne der Nacht morgen gibt
es shower im Nordosten und nach Norden
hin die ziehen zwar ab aber es gibt
viele Wolken also die partiell
Sonnenfinsternis ist dort eher schlecht
zu erkennen im Süden das Gegenteil hier
scheint häufig die Sonne und das bei
Temperaturen bis 21 Grad im Südwesten
Deutschlands und 15 Grad an der Ostsee
und es wird noch wärmer in den nächsten
Tagen 23 Grad und schaue am Mittwoch 24
Grad am Donnerstag und 25 sogar am
Freitag ein schöner Abend